the Disney Channel is pretty spot-on
when it comes to capturing those awkward
moments from our adolescent years
embarrassing moments are a part of
nearly every single one of their shows
so we decided to list our top favorites
watch until the end to come face-to-face
with the most awkward moment in Disney
Channel history
I'm page 73 of your health books what
they're trying to teach you is Jesse
unrequited love there's nothing more
embarrassing than thinking your rights
only to find out that you're totally
wrong have you ever seen someone waving
and even though you don't know the
person you wave back only to find out
they were actually waving at the person
behind you but for a minute there you
thought it was totally possible for a
complete stranger to enthusiastically
wave at you because well you're just
that awesome well the same can be said
for Jesse in the episode titled but
Africa is so far e only this time
instead of Jesse mistaking an
enthusiastic wave she is mistaking a
declaration of love in the scene brick
says sweetheart get everyone back into
the truck and Jesse is confident that he
is talking about her she points out that
since he called her sweetheart he must
still love her but then Brooks says I
was talking to Kimmy she's my girlfriend
ouch Zuri does little to ease the
embarrassing moments in fact she calls
it out when she says awkward yep that's
pretty much what everyone was thinking
at the time we can only imagine how
embarrassing that must have been of
course she handles it like a champ
don't worry Jesse we've all had our
awkward moments Liv and Maddie it's true
that many teenagers dream of the day
when they can get behind the wheel of a
car and hit the open road on their own
unfortunately there's just one little
problem we all must overcome we must
take and pass a driving exam before
we're legally allowed to go for a spin
not only is there a written exam which
can be impossible to pass if not taken
seriously there is also the actual
hands-on driving test with the DMV
certified official in an episode of Liv
and Maddie there's a lot of excitement
surrounding their driving tests while
Maddie is excited about the potential
freedom a driver's license will provide
is less than enthused
try loss of freedom who wants the drive
when you can sit shotgun and text until
you thumbs fell off
everyone has decorated the place to
celebrate the girls getting their
licenses but things didn't quite work
out the way they thought Liv strolls in
and tells everyone that only one of them
passed the exam much to everyone's
surprise that someone is Liv this means
Maddie failed when everyone realizes
this they rushed to pull down all the
decorations before she walks in maddie
is super disappointed she was all set to
drive around town in the minivan that
smells like Joey's feet but she just
couldn't master those left-hand turns
but failing a driving test is something
that can happen to anybody
in fact failure is the very thing that
makes success even sweeter Girl Meets
yearbook if you've ever been to junior
high or high school you know the
excitement of flipping through the fresh
pages of a shiny new yearbook to see
what your pictures look like we all hope
to have high-quality images of ourselves
that reflects the impressive individuals
we aspire to be but often times we open
our yearbook and scream when we see the
exact opposite of what we thought we
looks like oftentimes classmates will
give each other a title or superlative
status but what if that title is less
than the flattering in Girl Meets World
Farkle and Riley how to deal with this
totally relatable yearbook drama in this
episode Riley and farkles marched
through the hall handing out new
yearbooks Riley declares that yearbooks
allow the students to find out who they
are and what they really think about
each other Farkle adds that these
yearbooks will show them how they will
be remembered then Farkle opens up to
his page and sees that he has been voted
most likely to be Farkle and Riley one
most likely to smile herself to death
they're making fun of me and they're
making funny YouTube but Lucas tries to
point out that what we think of
ourselves is more important than what
others think of us but has a teenager
it's easy to get wrapped up and what
others think that awkward moment when
you realize someone is making fun of you
can severely bruised your ego even if
you're a Disney star but luckily Riley
doesn't let that stop her from being
herself and emac the crush problem what
could possibly be worse than when you
and your friend both have a crush on the
same person in high school this is a
serious problem and Disney Channel's
Andy Mack demonstrates it perfectly in
the episode were
and Jonah have that adorably awkward
moment together in front of Cyrus and
Buffy the thing that makes it even more
awkward is that Andy isn't the only one
crushing on Jonah cyrus has a crush on
him too so while Andy and Jonah keep
asking each other if they are okay Cyrus
is dying on the inside he feels that he
can't tell Andy that he also has a crush
on the same guy Cyrus you can have all
those things you just have to tell her
many friendships have been ruined by a
crush triangle Cyrus doesn't want to
risk losing a friendship over a crash
he asks Buffy to be supportive and
non-judgmental which isn't necessarily
her strong suit my only concern is you
go on trying you didn't even make it two
seconds
it's definitely tricky territory but as
awkward as it may be
Buffy is probably right it's better to
talk about it with your friend rather
than risking losing the friendship or
suffering in silence then you can laugh
together about having a crush on the
same person Jesse a close shave many of
us have had this moment we go to a new
hair salon put on a smock and sit in
that squeaky rotating chair we look at
the scissor wielding stranger and trust
them with one of our most precious
possessions our appearance even if we
can only afford a $10 haircuts in Disney
Channel's Jesse's looks are just as
important it's clear that Luke needs
some help shaving so Bertram offers to
lend him a hand but it turns into a
full-blown disaster when Bertram
accidentally shaves the middle of Luke's
head after Zuri startles him
this results in Luke having to cope with
a very unflattering reverse mohawk the
funniest moment of the episode is when
Peyton tells Luke that he looks like he
got in a fight with a lawnmower and
hands him a toaster so he can see his
reflection he looks at his crazy hairdo
in the toaster and lets out a
high-pitched scream he is obviously
pretty shocked about his new bald strip
while most of us have had bad haircuts
Luke wins as the champion of the worst
haircut of all time girl meets the birds
and bees in girl meets she don't like me
mr. Matthews tries to teach the kids
about reproductive health and let's just
say he's not doing so hot mr. Matthews
is clearly horribly uncomfortable
talking about this aspect of the human
body with his pubis
students it also doesn't help that his
daughter is a student in this classroom
when smackle asks what do you want
absolutely mr. Matthews is all too glad
to give her the floor so he can avoid
the subject
smackle goes on to explain very vividly
what she has learned on page 73 of your
house books what they're trying to teach
you is check out mr. Matthews it's face
this class presentation has the students
and the teacher completely horrified but
those gestures are hilarious what do you
suppose she is trying to say with those
thumbs these kids got a lot more than
they bargained for in health class today
that's for sure if you've ever had to
endure the birds and bees talk with an
adult you can probably relate to the
awkwardness of the scene and it has made
so much worse by smack those colorful
interpretation this is a total fail for
mr. Matthews what is the body what does
the body want I'm gonna tell you soup
Ravens home a private sandwich moment in
Disney Channel's Ravens home there are
plenty of laugh-out-loud moments but
there is one moment in particular that
we thought was especially awkward
there's a scene where Bravin is making
herself a sandwich that's a totally
normal thing but Raven is actually
talking to her sandwich she is
seductively placing tomatoes on the
bread and softly whispering Eden is bad
maybe you've had that food trance
momments in the kitchen before if you
have you'll the tests and it is a very
private moment that no one should ever
witness it would be super embarrassing
if anyone walked in on you while you
were talking to a sandwich right well
that's exactly what happens to Raven
she's about to connect her lips to this
heavenly sandwich when her roommate
chimes in from the edge of the kitchen
her roommate casually says she's
starting to worry that Ravens been
single for too long but of course Raven
doesn't miss a beat she says she loves
being single because it means she
doesn't have to share her sandwiches
with other people and everyone would be
as cool as Raven if they were caught
whispering sweet nothings to their
Turkey on rye this awkward moment is
totally delicious who else is hungry for
a sandwich now Hannah Montana the
grandma brawl this is the most awkward
moment in Disney Channel history
it's from one of the classic Disney
Channel shows Hannah Montana while it's
highly unlikely that most people would
relate to this awkward moment it is too
good to exclude from this list in this
episode Hannah Montana is receiving a
music award backstage Miley's mom all
Ruthie enter aunt dolly played by Dolly
Parton are arguing about where Miley got
her sense of humor Ruthie claims that
Miley got her sense of humor from her
while dolly says she's always thought
Miley learned how to get a chuckle out
of an audience from watching her on
stage she even points out it was thought
ahead wonderful comic man oh I know what
Elvis was thinking about and honey trust
me it had nothing to do with your mind
not too touchy subjects because in high
school Ruthie had a crush on Elvis but
dolly stole him away so a brawl takes
place behind Miley while she is giving
her speech Miley talks about sharing her
award with two women who continued to
inspire her with their character
strengths and class ironically enough
Miley says these touching words while
dolly and Ruthie are engaged in a
full-on WWF fight which is happening in
front of everyone Miley's dad tries to
break up the fight which is a huge
mistake
he gets body slammed to the ground
within a matter of seconds Miley is of
course totally embarrassed by this epic
grandma battle and while we haven't all
been on stage receiving a huge Music
Award most of us can relate to being
publicly embarrassed by our relatives
what was your favorite awkward Disney
Channel moment which of these
embarrassing moments has happened to you
don't be shy tell us in the comments
below
we've all got those embarrassing stories
right did you get caught talking to your
sandwich did you and your best friend
have a crush on the same person what is
your worst haircut story we want details
people before you go don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up and
subscribe to the things for more awesome
content thanks for watching we'll see
you next time
[Music]